[Music]
it's good to see you all here again I'm
very excited about what we're gonna be
sharing tonight and I'm very thankful
that we've got such a good group I want
to ask you all if you would let's ask
the Lord to be with us while we open his
word Father in Heaven we ask you in
faith for your blessing tonight send
your angels to guard and protect us open
our eyes that we might see your glory we
thank you in Jesus name Amen
tonight's message is called echoes of
Eden ye shall be as gods I want to I
want to open with the text of Scripture
in Isaiah chapter 51 and the Lord has
inspired me he's told me open with truth
and closed with truth all the stuff in
between make sure you open with with
truth and you close with my word
so in Isaiah 51 the Lord tells us he
says hearken unto me you that are
seeking after striving for righteousness
and then he says in verse 2 look unto
Abraham your father Abraham was a
hundred years old it was impossible for
him to generate seed at a hundred that's
it's out of the picture he says look
unto Abraham your father and unto Sarah
that bare you she was 90 that's
impossible
and God was trying to show us you that
are seeking to develop righteousness on
your own look to Abraham and Sarah he
says for I I called Abraham alone means
he had no children and I blessed him and
I increased him and then in verse 3 and
this is a promise that my wife and I
have claimed for our family it says for
the Lord
shall comfort Zion he will comfort all
of your waste places he will make your
wilderness like Eden and your deserts
like the Garden of the Lord joy and
gladness shall be found therein
Thanksgiving and the voice of melody
that is a promise and God cannot lie and
my wife and I we claimed that promise
for our marriage when the Lord brought
us back together and for our children
because there were so many wounds that
had been caused there in both of our
lives and in our children's lives and
and I was trying to fix them but God was
like look at Abraham there's no way he
could fix it on his own I had to do it
and the Lord promises us I will do this
2nd Corinthians chapter 11 verse 2 and 3
it says I fear lest by any means as the
serpent beguiled Eve as he mesmerised or
hypnotized Eve through his subtlety so
your minds should be corrupted from the
simplicity that's in Christ I like to
look words up and the reason why is when
I read this verse my whole life I was
like I don't want your minds to be
corrupted from the simplicity that's in
Christ and I was like you just kind of
read over it and you it doesn't have any
meaning and when I looked at it I was
like the simplicity that's in Christ
what does that mean when you look up the
word simplicity in its original in a
Strong's it means the singleness or
oneness that's in Christ and when I saw
that all the sudden it became beautiful
because other scriptures then tied in
with that and made sense John chapter 10
and I encourage you to read these verses
I'm not gonna quote all of them John
chapter 10 verse 30 through 38 Jesus
said I and my father are one
he just said here the simplicity the
oneness that is in Christ Jesus said I
and my father are one John 17 it says
these words spake Jesus and lifted up
his eyes to heaven and said I pray
father that they all may be one that
word in Hebrew is Akkad it means in
Union or United as one I pray that they
all might be one as thou father art in
me and I in thee that they also may be
one in us growing up as a Christian a
seventh-day Adventist Christian often
times I would read things but it was
just surface do you know what I mean it
was like I would read it but never
really comprehend what it was saying and
when I looked at what Jesus said here
father I pray that they might be one as
we are one and then he said I and my
father are one
there's a verse in 1st Corinthians I
believe it's chapter 6 I want to I want
to touch on let me check here 1st
Corinthians chapter 6 yes verse 16 and
17 our Father in Heaven tells us don't
you know he says what know ye not that
he which is joined to a harlot is one
body they become one I never
comprehended that I thought physically
okay but what difference does that make
they're one for an hour and then he
leaves or she
leaves and it's over that's not how it
works when a man is joined to a woman
they become one and that means if there
are any evil spirits that are active in
her life when he becomes one with her
Satan and his fallen angels now have
legal rights to his life maybe not in
the same degree but they have access
because he yielded I wish somebody had
taught me that when I was a young man
how many of us you know so our Wild Oats
and they you know I'll straighten up
when I get older I cannot tell you how
many men of God that are elders or
deacons or evangelists or pastors that
write to us and they'll say I've been
married for 20 years but I can't get
this woman these thoughts these memories
of this woman out of my mind
the first thing I ask is were you ever
intimate with them in any way shape or
form and they'll say yeah it was when I
was in college but it was 20 years ago
I'm happily married I don't want these
thoughts and I tell him I say when you
joined yourself to them there was a tie
that was made it's called a soul tie you
became one with that person and if that
person has got evil spirits that are
active in their life those spirits now
have legal rights to your life listen to
what the Lord says he talks about a man
being joined to a harlot and then listen
to what he says but he that is joined
unto the Lord is one spirit when we come
into union with Christ the same power
and presence that he had from his father
is now ours because we are here
his bride his flesh in his bones that is
a powerful promise and I have found over
the last 10 years since we've had our
ministry every one of those people that
came to us that was in bondage the
moment they would confess and tell the
Lord I'm willing for you to cut the
umbilical cord between me and this
person to cut the ties I'm willing to
give up all the memories all the
feelings all the emotions that I've held
on to concerning that person the moment
they do that and they claim the shed
blood of the Lord Jesus Christ the ties
are broken and they they they call back
and they're like I'm free for the first
time in 20 or 30 years I'm free
I'm not having dreams I'm not having
thoughts anymore
I say praise the Lord our God is able so
jesus said his last prayer before
Calvary was father I want them to be one
Genesis chapter 3 verse 1 through 5 now
the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the Lord God
had made and he said unto the woman and
I'm consolidating these text he said
unto the woman ye shall not surely die
for God doth know that in the day ye eat
thereof then your eyes shall be opened
another word for that is enlightened
make a note of that then your eyes shall
be opened and you shall be as God's
knowing both good and evil the word
knowing there means able to discern for
yourself what Satan was saying and you
can read this in patriarchs and prophets
chapter 1 he was saying if you'll just
taste my word
eat the bread that I'm giving to you
you'll find out that you don't need
God's divine influence anymore in your
life you don't need to hear that still
small voice telling you this is the way
my son or daughter walky in it that's
what Satan said in heaven he told God
your law is impossible nobody can keep
it do you know the only way that the
angels could keep God's law we're going
to show you a quote tonight Ellen White
says in desire of Ages page 161 that
from the beginning of creation it was
God's purpose that every created being
would be a dwelling place for him Satan
said I don't want you living inside me
I'm a big boy let go of my hand daddy I
can do this on my own
and so when Satan was battling with the
issue over God's law the reason it was
such a struggle for him was he was
trying to do it on his own and that's
what he has been trying to get mankind
to do every since Eden you can do it on
your own you don't need him holding your
hand do you know what the Lord Jesus
Christ said when he came to this earth
it actually says in Isaiah he said daddy
don't let go of my hand don't I can do
nothing without you don't let go of my
hand and he did that as our example
depend on him
trust in him from eternal ages it was
God's purpose that every created being
from the bright and holy serif or angels
to man should be a temple for the
indwelling of the Creator that that that
changes everything
and it's gonna get better as we go along
but to realize that was God's purpose
from the very beginning but because of
sin humanity ceased to be a temple for
God what did Adam and Eve wear what kind
of clothing were they wearing before
they felled us in light robes of light I
want to encourage you to consider
something I don't believe the robes were
something that were put on the outside I
say it was because God was dwelling
within that they were glowing do you
remember what the Apostle Paul says we
have this treasure in earthen vessels
do you remember Gideon they had those
torches and they had a clay pot over top
what happened when they burst the clay
pot it was brilliant light what happened
to Moses when he came down from spending
40 days in the presence of Almighty God
in Christ he didn't even realize because
he was so filled with God's presence his
face was glowing and it was so bright
that the people literally told him
you're gonna have to put a veil on your
face we can't look at you do you know
Daniel chapter 12 verse 1 through 3 says
the very same thing is about to happen
to all of us it says then shall be a
time of trouble such as never was and
they that turn many to righteousness
shall shine as the firmament
I think that's literal and when you read
what Ellen White says she says the same
thing we will literally glow just like
Moses did just like Stephen did you
remember when they were about to stone
him they they said his face looked like
an angel space that wasn't soft and
passive it was glowing every time you
saw an angel
in the Bible people fell on their face
like dead men it was that much power
because of sin humanity cease to be a
temple for God darkened and defiled by
evil the heart of man no longer revealed
the glory of the Divine one now here's
the beautiful part but by the
incarnation of the Son of God the
purpose of heaven is fulfilled what was
the purpose of heaven from eternal ages
it was God's purpose that every created
being should be a temple for the
indwelling of the Creator Christ became
flesh do you remember John chapter 2 he
was there at the temple and he told the
Pharisees he said he saw everybody they
thought their temple was such a
magnificent structure he said destroy
this temple and in three days I will
raise it up and the unbelieving Jews
they said it took 46 years for this
temple to be built are you gonna rebuild
it in three days and it says but this
Jesus was speaking of the temple of his
body now let me ask you a question what
does the Apostle Paul tell us about that
know you not that you are the body of
Christ Ephesians 5:26 and you are the
Temple of the Living God Christ did
something as our substitute and our
surety and if we will take hold of that
by faith we can lay hold on the promise
that God will now dwell in us again God
designed that the temple at Jerusalem
should be a continual witness and a
continual witness to the high
Destinee open to every soul jesus said
behold I've set before you an open door
the high destiny opened to every soul
but the Jews had not understood the
significance of the building they
regarded with so much pride they did not
yield themselves as temples for the
divine spirit let me ask you a question
do you remember what was on the curtains
inside the temple angels were they
painted on the outside of the curtain
they were embroidered now what is the
difference between me painting on a
shirt and embroidering a shirt
embroidery is much more expensive much
more expensive because the thread is
actually woven into the fabric now let
me share something with you that the
Lord revealed to me do you remember when
Nathanael came to Jesus and Jesus and
and Jesus told him you know I saw you
when you were under the fig tree praying
and Nathanael said my Lord and my god
and Jesus said do you think this is
something he said hereafter you will see
the angels of God ascending and
descending upon the Son of Man he was
the temple and just like those curtains
had angels ascending didn't and
descending upon those curtains that was
a shadow of what God wanted to do inside
of each of us and Christ said you're
going to see that in me
through sin the temple of God which he
had builded not man which he had builded
for his own glory was reduced to ruin it
was fallen and in decay Satan beguiled
the holy pair to their own destruction
and he introduced an element of
character that was antagonistic to God
and their fellow-creatures that element
of character was self-centeredness and
selfishness that was unknown in heaven
he introduced that to Adam and Eve now I
want to show you Eastern the Eastern
mystical philosophy this is a yellow
page ad it could be in any yellow page
anywhere in the United States if you go
home tonight and you open your yellow
pages and you turn to martial arts or
karate I can assure you you're gonna
find something almost identical to this
self-discipline self confidence self
esteem honor self control self defense
what are those all have in common self
you know I can't find one place in the
Bible where it says anything about
self-defense
I can I can find promises where God says
I'm your defense I'm not saying that
somebody should lay down and watch
somebody hurt their children or their
wife but what I am saying is is if you
need to defend yourself you can go buy a
can of pepper spray for twenty-five
dollars at any sporting goods store it
takes no training
there's no occult attachment if you go
to a martial arts because you want to
learn to defend yourself and I know
because I taught it trained in it and
taught it for 25 years you're gonna
spend on average fifty to eighty dollars
per month two classes per week at least
two hours per class
and even then you've only got about a
50% chance that you're gonna win that's
that's not good odds it's a lot of money
and then on top of that you've got the
occult background in those arts if
you're afraid for your life if you don't
have you know enough faith yet to
believe that God will really do what he
promised by pepper-spray it's a much
cheaper and much easier way to take care
of a problem this is a quote out of the
bhagavad-gita it's the Hindu scriptures
and they're talking about yoga they say
yoga is the journey of self through the
self to the self it's not the character
of our Savior is it now I want to tie
this together with what we've seen so
far dr. John Harvey Kellogg when he
first began voicing publicly what he
believed in his pantheistic views he
decided he wanted the book to be printed
called the living temple and the reason
he wanted to print this book he found a
good excuse for it let me say that the
the Battle Creek Sanitarium
had burned and Ellen White had warned
that there was potential this was going
to happen
before it happened you can look that up
in her writings
she had warned because it was becoming a
hub instead of instead of God's people
spreading out throughout the nation and
throughout the world
they were congregating in one spot and
she said this is not God's will and then
with with what was happening with
Kellogg with this pantheism he was
beginning to teach these ideas to the
staff to a lot of the other doctors that
were there as well as he was
having an influence on 80 Jones and EJ
Wagner and God burned the Battle Creek
Sanitarium to the ground in order to
help raise funds to rebuild the
sanitarium which Ellen White said was
not God's will that it be done Kellogg
said I've got an idea I'll write a book
in my in my feelings in my heart I think
he already had the book probably a good
way being completed this was just a good
reason to have it printed so he went to
the review and Herald publishing house
and said I want to have this printed
they had the plates on the line they
were ready to start the printing the
night that God burned down the
publishing house and Ellen White had
warned about that as well
she told him she told the publishing
house don't print this book this book is
not to be published and God burned the
printing house to the ground
because of it you know what Kellogg did
instead of taking the warning he went to
a secular publisher and he said I want
the book printed I believe it on the
first printing that he printed 5,000
copies anyway what is startling is the
book is now being printed again I was
doing some research before we started
these series because I thought it was
2015 I actually found where the book the
closest or the nearest one I was able to
find was 2009 so now it's being printed
even by non seventh-day adventists even
by non-christians and it's being
promoted as a book on the the everywhere
'no sub the pantheistic ideas so there's
many people that have no interest
the Lord God Almighty Jehovah Yahweh or
his son but the yet they're reading this
book and they're passing it out to
people because of the the other
teachings that are included Kellogg and
many of the people that we saw in the
first evening they were influenced
heavily by Hinduism by Hindu thought so
that's what we want to look at this
that's why these books are being printed
again the religion of of Hinduism it is
a physical as well as spiritual religion
that means you know we are Christians
and so it's natural for a Christian to
fellowship with a congregation or a
church we go to church we go to Bible
study we we do things that a Christian
would do in Hinduism the physical
activity is called yoga you cannot
separate the stretching from the
religion it's impossible and there's a
very powerful documentary a lady had
done a few years ago the video is called
yoga uncoiled the lady that did it she
passed away recently strong Christian
she wasn't of our faith but if you're
interested she did a lot of research she
actually had spent the first 20 years of
her life involved in this but what she
found was is through the interviews with
Hindu gurus and with Indian people that
had given their lives to Christ that
used to be Hindu Yogi's and gurus and
they said you cannot separate Hinduism
from yoga when you go to many of the
yoga web sites they will tell you this
is their words they say our goal is to
evangelize the world with Hinduism and
we have six
see did the greatest success in the
western states we've achieved the
greatest success and the reason they
attribute their success is because they
say they have a church on every street
corner it's called a yoga studio that's
where their religion is taught yoga has
become mainstream you see there on the
left-hand side of the page there's a
book written by Laura Staten and Sarah
Perrin called baby ohm when people chant
that mantra a mantra is not just a word
repeated it's a Hindu word it's a
Sanskrit word it means a word that is
voiced for a sound that is voiced
repeatedly in order to channel or invoke
a Hindu deity when they say ohm they are
actually channeling what's known as the
Sun God by the Hindus the Buddhists and
the Taoist this book is baby ohm yoga
for mothers and babies they've got books
out now for mothers that are pregnant on
how to do yoga so the child is coming
out of the womb already under the
influence of evil spirits if you look at
the center pictures this is a picture of
a very popular tea natural herbal tea
you may be able to find this at any
grocery store every grocery store I've
been in in this country I've been able
to find them
it's called yogi tea they have changed
their packaging in recent years used to
be this is what it looked like four or
five years ago they have downplayed the
blatant religion on the front but if you
turn to the side of the box every single
box has got a yoga instructions on how
to do a pose or a yoga or a Hindu
scripture on the side of every box
now what's interesting is is on the
front of this one is on this coffee or
tea mug is a black elephant and they
make yoga and Hinduism out as if it's
this beautiful thing even back in the
1800s when I read some of the
Enlightenment teachers and the
transcendental teachers like Henry
Thoreau and some of the others and they
talked about Hinduism and you and India
like it was the grand ultimate of
everything let me show you a little of
what their gods look like here in the
center is Ganesh
that's the Hindu elephant God that's the
one that you saw in the front of that
tea mug over to the left is a monkey God
where it's the amalgamation of man with
animal you have a monkey's face on a
human body you have an elephant's head
on a human body over to the far right
those are men that are known as God men
they are supposed to have entered into
nirvana
they have achieved that state of
nothingness in this world it means
complete possession and we look at that
and we say how can people look at that
and think that is a beautiful thing why
would you want that India their religion
is a very sensual religion that's why I
don't encourage people to do a lot of
research on yoga you've got to be
careful you got to pray because if you
type in yoga almost every ad that's
gonna come up is going to be sensual I
mean most of the people that are
involved in yoga classes they have these
yoga pants which are spray paint it's
pretty much like so what a superhero
would wear you sprayed this stuff on and
you're wearing that why would you have
to wear something that's so skintight to
practice yoga why not wear something
that's loose and baggy it seems like it
would be easier to stretch that way
many of the advertisements they'll have
men and women wear much more of their
body as exposed than is right morally so
the the religion itself is very sensual
but yet when you talk to people that
have worked in India many of the cities
are filthy I mean they're filthy because
of the way that religion classifies
people people that are on the bottom
you're not supposed to help them because
they believe in reincarnation and if you
help that person then you're not
allowing them to pay for their their
sins on their own and that means when
they get reincarnated they're gonna have
to go through it again
so they leave people where they are the
word yoga
etymologically it is connected to the
English word yoke tell me a Bible verse
that uses the word yoke come unto me all
you that labor and are heavy laden and I
will give you rest take my yoke upon you
and learn of me for I am meek and lowly
in heart the word yoga in the Sanskrit
Hindu language means union with Brahma
that's the Hindu god or union of the
little ego self with the divine self the
infinite spirit Yoga is primarily a
spiritual discipline that's from inada
Sangha worldwide they are one of the
largest yoga organizations in the world
and they tell you we have all kinds of
Christians that will tell us no it's
just physical it's just stretching but
they say otherwise
they tell you it is primarily a
spiritual discipline according to a
recent USA Today study Yoga has grown to
be a 27b
Ioan dollar industry with an estimated
20 million practitioners in the United
States of America alone I can remember
20 years ago if you wanted to find stuff
for practicing yoga you had to go to a
yoga school now you can go to any
Walmart and they've got almost an entire
aisle of just paraphernalia for yoga
videos and books and mats and clothing
and whatever and many doctors are now
promoting it it's being brought into
Christian churches as well
it makes yoga one of the fastest-growing
health and fitness activities in the
world this was a special issue in 2003
of Time magazine and it says how your
mind can heal your body and it has this
lady doing a yoga pose people are
looking at this and they're saying the
devil has left the pendulum swing he
took us over here to where it was strict
legal ism and there was no experiencing
the presence of God and he knew if I
could get people over there it'll only
last so long and it'll swing full swing
to the other side and they will be
willing to accept any kind of experience
that's why Satan inspired communism he
knew in communism there was no God it
was a secular you know nation you all of
Europe that was under communism and
Russia now the people are starving for
spirituality and that's why Satan is
able to find easy access to them they
were so dry that now they'll drink
anything that's offered to them while
those who are devoted to these Sciences
laud them to the heavens because of the
great and good works which they affirm
are wrought by them they know little
what a powerful for evil
they are cherishing but it is a power
which will yet work with all signs and
lying wonders with all deceivableness of
unrighteousness mark the influence of
these sciences dear reader for the
conflict between Christ and Satan is not
yet ended this is a movie that came out
a number of years ago called avatar has
anyone in here ever heard of it before
it was one of the largest grossing films
that has ever been produced the the
graphics and the special effects they
have never seen this type of work before
it was produced by James Cameron I'm not
sure if he was director and producer but
I know it was his film he was the one
that was giving credit for it in this
film and I do not recommend anybody go
see it not even for examination I've
never seen it I've done reading about it
and that was enough in this film mankind
found out that our planet was going to
be destroyed that we were at some sort
of crisis point and so we started
looking for another planet that we could
survive on and mankind found another
planet but it was inhabited by these
blue creatures and these blue creatures
were sort of like the Native American
Indians they weren't very happy about us
showing up on their doorstep and what
man did what humanity did was they said
we were trying to fight them but we're
not winning we're on their territory so
they came up with an idea they said if
we can blend a human being with one of
them his mind the humans
inside of their body we can then destroy
them from the inside out that sounds
demonic doesn't it what was scary was is
that after the movies huge success
I found CNN they had an article on their
website it may still be available if you
type in avatar CNN see what it brings up
on this blog that CNN the news
broadcaster had they said this film has
caused something to come across our desk
that we've never seen before they said
we are receiving thousands of emails and
letters from people that went to see the
film and there they're all saying that
they are now having suicidal thoughts
after seeing the film they had never
experienced this before what CNN said
was the only thing we can attribute this
to is the environment and the world that
was portrayed in that film was so
surreal that when people came out of the
film and they saw real-life it was a
letdown
that's what CNN said I don't think it
was that I think there was more
happening behind the masks in Hollywood
than what they realize when you see
where the idea came from for avatar it
will startle you and just to let you
know if anybody here is involved in
social media have you ever seen that
word in social media before avatar if
you sign up for a Facebook page it's
going to ask you to choose an avatar
that means a symbol to represent you if
you go to Twitter or if you go to
Facebook if you go to WordPress if you
go on any of those they will ask you to
choose an avatar and you can pick one
that they offer
you can go online and you can buy
different images or you can just put a
picture of yourself but they actually
call it by this Hindu name an avatar the
word in Sanskrit literally means those
who descended or fell from the heavens
that's what the word avatar means on
their website I looked it up on a Hindu
dictionary that is the definition of the
word those who descended or fell from
the heavens now these are actual real
Hindu avatar on the left you see the the
statue the idol it's a blue man he has a
Cobra that is wrapped around his neck
that's what the devil always says look
I'm really not going to bite you I'm not
gonna hurt you you won't surely die so
he hangs loosely about the neck but he's
like a boa he's slowly drawing the noose
closer and closer until he's able to
squeeze off all the oxygen now what is
air a symbol of in the Bible God spirit
do you know that people that have pride
they often struggle with being able to
believe God's promises pride is a spirit
that is very similar to that it cuts off
the connection between the brain and the
heart so you can read the Bible and you
can even understand the the Greek in the
Hebrew but you have a very difficult
time believing and and sensing and
knowing and feeling God's love and his
presence in your life and Satan's
content with head knowledge but he
doesn't want it making it to the heart
because once the heart is gained
surrender comes and Christ reigns now if
you look over on the right
inside of the page this is an old
depiction of another avatar remember the
word avatar means those that came down
or fell from heaven not all angels look
the same not all demons are fallen
angels or evil spirits are there not
cookie-cutter
they all have different ranks they have
different organization they have
different skills even Ellen White talks
about that some of them they influence
Hollywood some of them their job is to
influence writing read that book by
Roger Moore no a trip into the
supernatural he tells the exact same
thing they have different fallen angels
that give different gifts they have
different operation this one on the
right she's holding a symbol a medallion
that's also known as a mudra not a
mantra but a mudra it's a symbol that
she's like a talisman it opens the door
and it invokes fallen spirits
she's holding this in her hand it's a
six-pointed star with a circle in the
middle of it many people think that's
the Star of David even though the Bible
tells us clearly God never ever once
used that symbol for his people the only
record we can find of a Hebrew person
using that symbol is in a bad way the
book of Acts and also I believe Amos
talks about the children of Israel
worshiping the God Moloch and his star
and then there are occult records that
talk about King Solomon when he went
into apostasy and he was worshiping all
the hosts of heaven they say that he the
Bible doesn't but the occult says he
used this symbol it was used as the seal
to open and close doorways to the spirit
world now what's amazing to me is this
painting is an old depiction do you see
the four children she
holding red and yellow and black and
white all are precious in His sight you
remember that song Jesus loves the
little children
she's holding all the children of the
world in her arms she is feeding them
that's what that picture is saying she
is giving them their nourishment and
she's holding this symbol up now look at
this man
this is Pope Benedict do you see what's
on his tiara the exact same symbol the
word Catholic means universal and we
talked about this on the first night in
order for Rome to bring all of her
children home she has to have common
ground with each of them you see that
same symbol they see that symbol and
they know that he worships the same gods
that they do this is a Japanese
Grandmaster his name was more EIU a
Sheba he was the founder of aikido he
said each and every master regardless of
the error or the place heard the call
and attained harmony with heaven and
earth then he says there are many paths
leading to the top of Mount Fuji but
there is only one summit love in our
next meeting I'm going to show you a
short video clip that will startle you
remember this when you see that video
clip he went on to say everyone has a
spirit that can be refined a body that
can be trained in some manner and a
suitable path to follow then he says you
are here to realize your inner divinity
and to manifest your in eighth
enlightenment this is what the occult
and what the Eastern mystical religions
are trying to get men to do they're
saying you don't need Christ you can do
this on your own last night when we were
talking we read a quote from Ellen White
she said these theories make of none
effect the atonement at 1:00 meant that
Christ has made for us we were made one
again with God through Christ Jesus if
you think that God is already in you and
you already are a god and all you have
to do is breathe a certain way or say
these mantras or do these stretches then
you don't need Christ and the Bible says
no man comes to the Father but by me
Satan is leaving millions to destruction
the sophistry is regarding God and the
and nature that are flooding the world
with skepticism are the inspiration of
the fallen foe who is himself a Bible
student who knows the truth that is
essential for the people to receive
Satan is not stupid
he knows what has to be done within our
lives that's why he has been fighting
since the 1800s to counterfeit
the third angel's message of
righteousness by faith that's why every
when you turn the television on after
seven o'clock in the evening you see one
commercial after another advertising
food that will put you in an early grave
and people go walk can't stop myself
from eating at ten o'clock at night
what suppose you've been watching it on
television all night and Satan knows
that do you know how difficult it is for
us to come
and biblical truth when we are yielding
to intemperance Satan was working on
both sides to destroy the truth that is
essential for the people to receive and
it is his study to divert minds from the
great truths given to prepare them for
what is coming upon the world after the
passing of time in 1844 we had
fanaticism of every kind to meet
testimonies of reproof were given to me
to bear to some holding spiritualistic
theories corruptions of every type
similar to those existing among the
antediluvian x' will be brought in to
take minds captive the exaltation of
nature has God the unrestrained license
of the human will the counsel of the
ungodly these Satan uses as agencies to
bring about a certain ends he will
employ the power of mind over mind to
carry out his designs the most sorrowful
thought of all is that under his
deceptive influence men will have a form
of godliness without having a real
connection with God like Adam and Eve
who ate the fruit from the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil many are even
now feeding upon the deceptive morsels
of error the experience of the past will
be repeated in the future Satan
superstitions will assume new forms
errors will be presented in a pleasing
and flattering manner false theories
clothed with garments of light will be
presented to God's people and thus Satan
will try to deceive
if possible the very elect now listen to
what she says most seducing influences
will be exerted minds will be hypnotized
when we talk about hypnosis and we
mentioned this the other night this
hypnosis is something that is being used
not only by pastors in our churches but
all churches
it's called neuro linguistic programming
it's being taught to martial arts
instructors one of my best friends I've
been friends with him for years high
level martial artists I went to see him
one time because I had a school and he
had had a school longer than I we've
been in the arts almost the same amount
of time but he had opened his own school
before I had and his school was growing
it was a really it was a big success and
I went down to see him because we always
exchanged ideas he trained in some arts
that I didn't train in and there was
some things that I had learned that he
hadn't had exposure to so we shared what
we were learning and I went down to see
him one time and he told me something he
said Eric he said we need to sit down
and talk about your school I said I
would love you know whatever advice you
can give me he said I went to a meeting
with some other masters here in the area
where he lived a large city in the
southern United States and he said one
of the men there knew a man that helped
corporate America corporate leaders and
he invited this man to come give a
seminar to all these martial arts
instructors and in my mind I was
thinking I mean what you what are you
inviting a guy from corporate America
what's he going to teach you all but I
was interested and I said you know what
weapon he said he taught us how to make
our schools grow unbelievably and when
he started sharing with me what the man
had taught instantly I knew it was NLP
when little Johnny and Susie's mom and
dad came in the man would you know be
there at the desk and he would smile and
he's talking to him and he's like well
listen you know and he's being friends
with the children and he said y'all I
know that you guys are here to sign up
so what I want to do is I want to go
ahead and just offer you a free week of
classes and what size does your daughter
wear what size is your son wear oh I
just happen to have the the uniform this
will look perfect on you that was made
for you that's in LP he's telling them
what they will buy he's telling them
what they will wear this will fit you
perfect I've had this one here all week
and I wasn't sure why and you walked in
tonight and I know this one's got your
name on it that is a very basic form of
NLP and he would tell them I actually
I've got your contract you know right
here ready for you and you don't have to
worry about you know this or that um you
know this is gonna be good your children
are gonna succeed and they walk out the
door and and my friend told me he said
Eric he said I started using this and he
said I haven't lost one person that
walked in the door not one not one it's
happening in our churches this mind over
mind is happening in our next meeting
we're gonna take a close look at this
let's close with prayer father in heaven
we thank you for your love for your
kindness and for your mercy and we thank
you for the light you have given us
through your son our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ send your angels to
fill this ministry in this room and
father fill our hearts with thy presence
alone
[Music]